schließlich leute und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem kleinen blog wissen
gerade auf der autobahn hier erkennen
dürfen und zwar geht es nach
max betreffe in köln
den blues text aus hamburg mutter
gekommen ist
in köln treffen und die patrick sehen
wir auf das heißt wir werden uns in köln
vereinigen unter unseren wesen treiben
außerdem mit der beiden ich habe meine
leben mit am start
auf den lader gewachsen wir haben sogar
dabei sind geplant anders als barcelona
es wird nicht leicht sein
schließlich einigte sich die krise beim
lernen muss aber
deswegen
zahlen müssen
dent
so nikolaus schaut euch warum wir das
wieder
die note 1
diese looks like
ein gelb zeigte köln gekommen
das wetter ist richtig
wir steuern jetzt einen punkt
ein porträt von mir den kran häusern
was
dort werden wir
fressen
wenn du das ich habe
ladies and gentlemen weil die jetzt in
den park ausdrehen und stehen genau
dahinter aber natürlich superschön
zeigen das kennzeichen nicht
somit hätten gar nicht zeigt sex mit
frauen
was haltet ihr davon schreibt in die
kommentare und um mich ein traum
ich finde es
und ich bin macht
machen
der film gerade im bürgerlich hin und
warten darauf in koblenz das wir essen
können
es wurde herzlich sagt dass wir 20
minuten warten müssen
da wasser aber des korrekten kosten
gespottet
juli
gerade schön
wir werden in seine zehnte abbildung war
wir werden deine tipps 1200 aufgegessen
ich hab natürlich vergessen zu gelangen
was ich gegessen habe euch zeigt sich
hier dieser bürgerlichen war ihr sehr
nice wird
leute ihr seht ihr den button auf dieser
service banken der wurde von sap nicht
misshandelt
diese service passen utah calla kommt
nämlich eine person gefragt was los ist
und auf meine frage hat und wir haben es
braucht einen
verarschen
ja also ich habe max hatten einmal
gedrückt geht markus
als wurde einmal geduld der knappen
ich mag also der waffen wurde einmal
gedrückt dann kam die frage wie ihr nein
denn ich idiot wir wissen was es ist
wird noch mal drauf kommen die noch mal
und dann
drücken den automaten drittes mal drauf
und die leute halten uns für arschlöcher
bis kommentieren eine schnauze oder
kleine sachen muss ich auch zeigen und
zwar präsentiert jetzt das fliegende
glas glas wasser auf
eigentlich hier
hat die durch
und jetzt 32
trainer wiederholt
eine kleine armee die polizei
rang
solisten sind wir waren uns gerade eben
hier oben
nach dem essen was geworden was darin
passiert weiß kein mensch wirklich jetzt
gleich noch einkaufen wenn man noch
besser merken und dann gehe ich nachher
noch mit luca ins bootshaus zu hause
mitgebracht oder so auf jeden fall mit
ins boot zu heiß auf den straßen
unterwegs
wir kaufen jetzt beim boutique lachen
hat folgt auf instagram folgt denn wir
machen jetzt eine currywurst überfallen
und dann ist wahrscheinlich denken
currywurst wir haben doch alles gegessen
aber schon eine ganze menge zeit es ist
natürlich ein erstes mal später und es
ist eine menge hightech ist fit ist eine
menge ihm später alles klar ja wir holen
jetzt auch eine currywurst eine sache 56
hallo ich sehe wenn ich weiter so sind
73 3 4 5 6 7 8
für mord und ich will keine currywurst
track ich mir gut und ich nicht denken
jetzt wird s nicht erarbeitet hätte
komplett noch khalid geht man ins
bootshaus feiern und das haus heute
gehen hier war dort am wald ich kann
euch noch erleben konnten
leider bin ich noch nicht acht den ihr
werdet mich im bootshaus in einer
späteren nachdem so leute herzlich
willkommen am nächsten morgen sind jetzt
gerade unterwegs und suchen uns
frühstück dann stellt sich als sehr
schwierig heraus sind die polito company
dazu jetzt gehen
so erwarten eine pizza essen
patrick rudolph vermessen und hinten
irgendwo steht luca weil die frau
bringen hat sich alle sechs passt fast
denken
willst du
die halle fertig es stand vorher schon
eine fülle schöne dabei die schon essen
und dann kommt jetzt so der knockout
die frau von nummer sechs bin und er
weint ein bisschen geschlagen
da steht kein mensch so
weil passt da standen alle ja es ist
lucia machen wir
ein paar jahre zu tun
470 youtube auto verschwiegen hat ein
flugzeug rein was wirklich ist zeigt die
trotz findest du hier hunde elisabeth
treskow platz und so meine lieben ist
jetzt soweit wieder köllges zusage und
nach hause zu fahren wir sind jetzt
gerade auf dem nachhauseweg besucher der
tankstelle weil du ein bisschen später
walnüssen online noch ein wenig gedreht
mit flughafen
das dürfte in den nächsten tagen auf
seinem teller kommen
das war's von köln lockt die anderen
sind wir hier einen der beschreibung
verlinkt max luger patrick deutlich
gefallen das gerne daumen nach oben da
und wir sehen zum nächsten video wieder
rein